[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello.
Welcome to my talk.
We're going to go
over system sleep.
I know you're all
really excited.
And I'm excited, because you
all decided to come in here
and spend an hour listening to
me as I try to convince you not
to do anything, like, at all.
Just don't even touch your app.
OK.
So I guess the
first question is,
why should you listen to me?
Here's a copy of my
bio from the website.
You can read it
again if you want to.
But not listed on this is I
work at Google, obviously.
I am an Developer
Advocate for Android.
And recently, I co-founded
this initiative called
Android Development Patterns.
We have a bunch
of videos online.
We put out pro tips every week.
And the intent here
is to teach people
how to do best practices, how
to build better apps by knowing
how to make a
decision as opposed
to how to implement an
API, because we have
a lot of coverage on the Java
docs, and in our documentation,
and on our other videos
on how things work.
And we want to teach
when and why things work,
and then how to
make that decision.
Am I talking too fast?
Sorry.
OK.
And so that's what ADP is about.
The other thing that I did
this year that's really cool
is I created the Advanced
Android App Development
course with Udacity.
And so we have this super cool
Nanodegree, which is awesome.
Teaches you everything you
need to know or just the pieces
that you might have missed.
And my course is the
second part of that.
And once you've learned the
basics of the operating system,
you want to learn
the fancier things,
like maybe how to integrate
with Google Cloud Messenger.
And so that's the kind
of stuff that we cover.
And we're really trying
to help you build not just
a simple sample
app, but to walk you
through how something
works in its entirety,
and when you have to go back
and iterate on the same app
that you've already finished.
We're trying to get more into
that developer experience
when we're teaching,
and so that it feels
more true to what your
life is and your experience
is going to be.
And then if it helps, I actually
started learning Android
last February, 2014.
And so I just want
to say that as, like,
a point of, hopefully, comfort.
You don't have to have been
doing this since the beginning,
and you don't have to have been
doing this for a very long time
to really pick it up and run
with it, because it does change
every year.
And you can really
get caught up quickly.
OK.
So maybe listen to me.
But if you don't, that's OK.
So today, the reason
we are all in this room
is because battery
actually matters
almost more than anything
else that we have.
And there has been
tons of press on this.
You see studies all
the time comparing
this device to that device,
which one runs better,
or this carrier to that carrier.
This one's clearly
better for battery.
It doesn't burn your radio.
Or buy this new thing,
because this tablet will
last all month, and
this other one will only
last a couple of days.
And everybody really
cares about getting power,
but nobody wants
to give up using.
And so it's kind of a trade-off.
And this is this big
problem for users
that everyone was
trying to solve.
So what we're
going to talk about
is how to solve
this by not making
it worse with background tasks.
And so clearly, you
know how this works.
You've got your activity, it
kicks off a background task,
your activity continues.
This is good for users,
because you're not
hanging up on the frame rate.
But what this is bad
for is the device,
because we get into
this situation, where
every app kicks off its
own background sync or job.
And none of them are
talking to anybody else,
and nobody knows
what's going on.
Everybody just
knows, like, I want
to get this done at some
point, and it doesn't really
matter when, so long as it's
done in time when I need it.
And this is what's worse,
because all of these things,
if you can't coalesce them,
you can't optimize for them.
So we want to, at the end
of our talk, move to this.
We want to be able to
say, three different apps
need to run a sync by this
time or under these conditions.
Run them all together.
And then later on, another
app needs to run a sync.
Like, let's run that
one when it can.
We want to be able to do this
in bulk every time we can
and not every 30 minutes
for somebody new.
And this is what's going to
save device battery the most,
because we can just not wake up
the CPU if it's not being used.
And we can not
drain the power when
nobody's even in the room,
which brings us to Doze mode.
Doze mode was introduced
in Android Marshmallow.
And the reason that
it was introduced
was so that we could, as
a framework, take control.
Other apps don't have insight
into what everyone is doing.
And you can only go so
far to make your app OK.
But if the framework
doesn't help,
we can't ever get
to that ideal state.
So unfortunately,
it doesn't really
matter what API
you're targeting.
If your user is on a
Marshmallow device,
this is going to affect you.
It goes back through all
SDKs for any device that
actually supports Marshmallow.
And that's why you need to
start thinking about it today,
because you won't know if
your users are really affected
or not.
So with Doze, we released this.
We got a lot of good press,
a lot of really good feedback
from the developer community.
So you would think we'd have
a really good list of goals
for why we did it.
But we don't.
We only have one.
We just want to preserve
the battery life,
because by doing that,
we're creating a better user
experience.
And that's what everyone, when
you're creating an operating
system, you need to emphasize.
So this is our one
goal for Doze--
do whatever we need
to to preserve battery
when we're in an idle state.
When the user's not
using it, we need
to do everything we can
see so that when they pick
their phone back up,
we're exactly at the 17%
that they had left.
But I have my own
goal for this talk.
And here's that goal.
I want you to learn to accept
that your user has a life.
You're spending so long
building this great app
that you're really invested in,
and you want your users to use.
And that's great.
You should keep doing that.
But you should understand
what success means when
we're talking about an app.
At Google, we actually count
success-- like Larry Page
will be super
proud of you if you
can pass his toothbrush test.
And that means if your user is
using your product two times
a day for a couple
of minutes a day.
That is successful.
So we're going for, like,
what, five minutes here?
Which means there's 23 hours
and 55 minutes in every day when
your user is not
interacting with your app,
but you're super
duper successful.
And when you think
about it like that,
it changes the way that you
actually design your app,
because you're
not going for them
using your app all day long.
You're not going for
constant, glued to the thing,
tripping over, getting
run over by a car.
You're going for
something that's
useful that they'll come back
and tell their friends about,
which means you don't need to
be updating every 20 minutes.
You just need to be ready
when they're using you,
which goes into what is Doze?
So Doze is when your
device is fully idle.
And what does that
actually mean?
So what we've got here is
network access is blocked.
If the device is not being
used, if we're in idle mode,
we don't allow network
access by anyone.
We just turn off the radio.
And that's going to
save us so much battery.
We also ignore wakelocks.
Sorry.
We're in Doze mode.
We don't really care that you
wanted to do something or go
on any further.
Any alarms that you set
with your Alarm Manager,
those are going to be deferred.
They're not going to
run while we're in Doze.
But because we'll have
missed the time window,
they'll all trigger as soon
as we exit out of Doze mode.
And finally, your syncs and
jobs, they just won't run.
They won't get deleted,
they won't get dropped.
But they will not run
through Doze mode, which
means when we exit Doze mode
and all those conditions
are met again, we'll run
them as soon as we exit,
unless, of course,
your time-to-life
has expired, because
it's no longer relevant.
But we're not just deleting
them because we're in Idle mode.
And I know that this sounds
kind of frustrating and kind of
scary, because as
a developer, you
need to know the state that
your app is going to be in.
And it seems like this
framework is standing up here,
telling you, we
don't really care,
we're deleting all
of your hard work.
And that's really not
true, which goes back
to my first point of
in 43 more minutes,
I want you to walk
out of here thinking,
I'm not going to change
my app, because I'm not
being hurt or damaged.
I'm just being maybe delayed.
So let's talk about how
we get into Doze mode.
Doze mode is triggered when
the device is not charging,
and the screen is
off, and the device
has not moved in a long while.
So what that looks like with
your phone, I put it down,
I kind of walk away.
I'm doing something
more important,
like talking to you guys.
But when I come back over
there, I better still be at 58%.
I'm going to be
really frustrated
if I get back here at the end
of this hour and I'm down to 13,
because I was playing
a game with my friends,
and it kept updating
while I wasn't using it.
That's just not a good
developer experience.
We really need users to
trust that their device is
in the state that they left it.
So the trade-off, though, is
that as soon as I put it down,
I'm not already dosing.
It doesn't happen as soon
as basic conditions are met.
We're actually going
to step into it.
This is a timeline of
what Doze looks like.
We start with--
like, everything that
is required to get into Doze.
And then you'll see that Doze
actually will give itself
some maintenance windows.
So we'll come back to that.
But this image, which
lives in our docs,
is kind of trying to
explain to you that we have
these checkpoints that happen.
We check for sensing,
we check for motion,
we check for pattern, we
check for [INAUDIBLE],
so that if you're
just walking away
to wash your hands or whatever,
you're not going to come back
and your phone's out of date.
We're stepping into Doze
from an inactive state,
so that we can be plenty
confident that the user is
actually done right now.
Like, they're doing
something else.
OK.
So those states are controlled
by DeviceIdleController.
You can actually
look into the AOSP
if you want to know
how this works.
But all you need
to really believe
me is that you've got a good
solid two hours of inactivity
probably before we
get into Doze mode.
So you won't end
up in a state where
your app is just cut off in
the middle of doing something.
So Active is where the device
is actually being used.
That's pretty obvious, right?
And Inactive is obviously
where it's not being used.
The screen has been turned
off and there's no motion.
We're not navigating.
We're not playing a song.
We don't have a foreground
process running.
We're just chilling in
someone's purse, right?
And then after half an
hour, DeviceIdleController
kicks back up, kicks
into Idle Pending
mode, because it saw
that we were inactive.
Nothing changed.
No other signals were processed.
And now we're just pending.
So we've been
inactive for a while.
We may become idle, but we're
waiting to be confident.
And once we're confident half
an hour later, we're like, OK,
we're idle.
This is Doze everybody.
This is happening.
Shut it down.
And then you saw those
maintenance windows.
That's measured by
Idle Maintenance mode.
And we also have a Sensing
and a Locating mode.
And if you want to
know more about those,
you can actually go look
them up in the documentation.
They just are with
getting to these states.
So if you go back to
look at our picture,
you'll see that we've moved
it through all of these states
with all of our constant checks.
And we have gotten to the
point where, OK, yeah, we
were sensing, not sensing,
locating not locating.
But we're still inactive.
We've gotten to Idle.
And so Idle Maintenance,
these other windows,
is actually where we step out
of Doze, because we understand
that you don't want to be out of
date when the user comes back,
right?
And so what we're going
to do is we're going to,
every so often in
the Idle period,
we'll just give
everyone a break--
let them run their syncs, their
jobs, update any content--
and then go straight
back into Idle mode.
And this is clean,
because it's our goal.
We got to a maintenance window.
Now we get to run
everything in a batch.
Everything that's pending
gets a chance to go.
And the user still hasn't
come back to their phone.
So there's really no actual
change to the device,
but your app gets a chance to
update any potential conflicts
or content that needs to go.
So look, we're so close to
solving our battery problem.
Like, we're there.
We had our little--
I can't go backward.
That's unfortunate.
I am bad at slides.
OK.
So we had our window.
We got to hit our window.
We got to run all
of our batch jobs.
And we hit our goal.
So now that you understand
how these states work-- which,
and the reason I went
into this background
is so that you'll
understand what
it means when I tell you
to test your app for Doze,
because we have these super
great adb commands that
will let you step
through all the states,
so you can see what your
app is doing along the way.
And you wouldn't
really understand
what I meant by "step"
if you didn't understand
what I meant by "stages."
See?
See how I did that?
OK.
So your focus is on
observing behavior
when you're doing this.
And you're seeing whether
your app recovers gracefully
when Doze exits.
Because remember,
we're aiming to not
have to do any work as
a result of this mode.
So when you're looking
at this adb thing,
dumpsys is just a
binary that lets
you access other tools by name.
And then you've got deviceIdle.
And this is a new
service that was
introduced, so that
you could manage
the DeviceIdleController.
And then obviously, step
will let you do those steps.
And h will show you all
the other options you have.
And then the other
key to testing
is you need to indicate that
the device has to be unplugged.
Most likely, when you're testing
and running out your db cans,
you've plugged in your
phone to the computer,
and now you're charging.
So you have to cancel that.
But when you're stepping through
and you're testing your device,
all you're seeing
here is whether or not
you're surprised by
anything, whether or not
that pause has actually broken
a part of your app behavior.
And the idea here,
when we created this,
is that it shouldn't,
because everything's on hold.
Everything's been paused.
The user's not anywhere
near their phone.
And yet, you're getting
a chance to still update
any potential content.
So now the question is, how
do we get out of Doze mode?
And what does it
really mean when we've
called it quits and we're done?
So the clear one here is that
the device is plugged in.
We don't care anymore
about whether or not
we're preserving battery,
because we're charging.
Or if the device is picked
up-- I'm so bad at slides--
then the user's clearly
interested in using it again.
The other thing, though, is that
if there's an alarm-- and not
an Alarm Manager alarm, but an
alarm, like an alarm clock--
then we're going to exit
Doze mode well before that,
so everyone has a chance to
sync before that user wakes up
from their nap.
Like, that's a really
key thing here.
So we've built
this entire system
with one goal, of
preserving the battery life.
And then we built it around
making a great user experience,
so they never know that
their device was idle.
All they know is that they
were gone for two days,
because they were hanging
out with their friends
and going camping,
and they came back,
and their tablet still works.
They pick it up,
everything's great,
and the tablet's still charged.
Like, it didn't die.
And that's a
phenomenal experience.
And if we can nail
that, we're going
to really, really make it so
that everything just is great.
And it also means that your
app is no longer to blame,
and the battery list,
and they come back,
and their thing is
dead, and they're
like, why was the news
running if I wasn't even here
to read it?
That doesn't make
any sense to me.
So hopefully, you don't
have to do anything.
You tested your app once, made
sure nothing wonky happened.
And then you're just all, OK,
great, I'm good, I'm done.
But if you actually
do have a use case
and you want to adapt
your app for Doze,
here's what you need to do.
First step, consider
the flow of your app.
Kind of talked about this.
But will Doze affect it?
If you think about how
your background syncs run
and your jobs run,
how important are they
to the core function of your
app when it's on a time schedule
or what expectations
your app has
for something
being done already,
likely, this
shouldn't affect it.
Because like I said, we
stepped into this carefully.
We accounted for things like
alarm clocks and the user
usage.
But you know, if it does, you'll
want to take a look at that.
So a common solution
here-- and this is actually
just a general best practice--
is to use downstream messaging.
If your server is expecting
your device to check in on it
and it misses that
connection, you
might think that
something's wrong.
But if you've built your app
so that your server sends
interesting information to
the device instead of having
to have a call-in,
then you're going
to have just a much better
user experience in general.
And then if you're using
Google Cloud Messaging,
you can take this further
and have a High Priority tag.
It's really easy to add.
You just add
priority-high to your data
as you build your
object for your message.
But a high-priority tag is
going to be given exceptions
from Doze mode.
It's going to be given a
chance to wake up a receiver,
process that message,
potentially react to it.
Maybe you need to generate
a notification off of that.
And this gives you a
temporary reprieve from Doze.
So most likely, you'll go
right back into Idle mode.
But if that notification
draws the user's attention,
then you're going to be able
to exit Doze mode entirely,
because the device will
have been picked up.
So you really get
a chance to react
to anything that's critical,
like real-time messaging,
and all kinds of apps like
that, or maybe a severe weather
alert.
I mean, it could be any kind
of thing that might drive them.
But it's not everything.
And I want to stress this,
because high-priority
should be treated with care.
And what high priority
really means--
and it's very simple
to remember this--
is if I have to get up,
walk across the room,
pick up my phone when I was
doing something more important,
like giving a talk,
and look at it,
it better have been worth it.
And if it's not worth
it, because you just
wanted to tell me that I
got a poke from a friend,
that's not the same thing.
So not everything's
high priority,
which is why you add
the tag to what counts.
And then the rest of
the time, everything
will be processed normally
as soon as the device is idle
again.
So we're really trying
to build overall
just a great user experience
with this entire program.
OK.
The other thing is something's
legitimately are time-critical.
You really do need it to trigger
at exactly the right moment.
Maybe you have a
reminder app or maybe you
have calendar invites going.
And these, we actually built
an alternative for you.
We created new
Alarm Manager calls.
So instead of calling
set or setExact,
you'll add AndAllowWhileIdle.
The methods are actually
exactly the same.
They take the same
parameters in the same order.
They're identical to
their counterparts
in all the calling.
The only difference is that
they're honored whether or not
you're in Doze.
So it's a really easy
swap for any developer.
But the one restriction
that we added
is that it can only be triggered
once every 15 minutes, which
is actually incredibly
reasonable if you think
about a device in Idle mode.
If you didn't get the user's
attention the first time,
they probably don't
care two minutes later.
15 minutes is actually a
very reasonable window.
And it allows for things
like a calendar reminder
without necessarily
triggering every 60 seconds,
waking up and checking to
see if new content came in.
And the final thing,
which I already mentioned,
is you really need
to test your app.
Like, make sure that you don't
get surprised by anything,
because if you're
surprised, your user's
going to be surprised.
And then that's just going
to result in uninstalls,
or not using your app,
or lower engagement,
because they don't
know how to use it.
So classic advice here all
around, not just for Doze.
Just test the app and
make sure it works.
The other thing is
I need to mention
that there is a white list
for Doze as an exception.
But it's only for a few
very special use cases
and is subject to the Play
Store developer policy.
So most of your apps
probably won't need this.
But if you do have
questions, you
can feel free to ask me later.
Or check the documentation
on how that white list works.
OK.
So that's Doze mode.
It has a counterpart.
And that's called App Standby.
And this was also
introduced in Marshmallow,
also affects all M
devices, whether or not
you're targeting it.
But the difference here
is that App Standby
was created for apps
while the device is still
running while Doze shuts
down the entire device.
So while Doze might result
in maybe everything being
out of sync by about
four hours, App Standby
could mean that your app
hasn't gotten any attention
in a couple of days.
And that's why you have to
think about this differently.
But again, we have one goal--
preserving battery life.
And so that's the
main thing to keep
in mind as you go through this.
So it's the exact
same problem before.
We need to achieve
this as much as we can.
And apps that aren't
being used are
a drain on the battery
when they're syncing.
And so we want to
batch all of those,
and our maintenance windows
will let us do that.
So kind of like why have both?
And here's the main use case.
So App Standby and Doze are
different in the main sense
of what they affect-- an app
at a time or the entire device.
They both restrict
network access,
so that nobody can
access the radio
while they're in this mode.
They both halt all
jobs and syncs,
because those are the
things we want to batch.
But alarms and
wakelocks are both
going to be honored while
we are in App Standby.
And this is what's going to
make all of the difference.
Because if your app hasn't
been used in a while
but is put on the
standby list, and then
your alarm is triggered because
you have maybe a daily reminder
or you have something
that's important,
and you need to present
that to the user
and get their attention
back to your app,
you're out of App Standby.
Like, as soon as you
present a notification,
you're good to go.
So you're not forced
by the system.
You're just kind of
halted while the system
notices you're not being used.
And then as soon as
you are being used,
you're immediately released.
And you have a
little bit of control
over how that gets triggered.
OK.
So when your app is
actually put on standby,
it's because the
user isn't using you.
They haven't opened your app.
They haven't interacted
with your app.
They haven't really
kind of touched it
at all in quite a long while.
And you don't have a foreground
service, or activity,
or another app
using a foreground
service that you wrote.
You're not playing any music,
you're not streaming anything.
You're just kind of chilling.
And then finally, you don't
have any pending notifications.
So this is why honoring
wakelocks and alarms
are so important, because
you do have a chance
to get yourself out of standby.
But for the most
part, you are only
put on standby, because you
are actually just chilling.
Like, nobody was using you.
So it's not that you're
not a successful app.
You're still passing
the toothbrush test.
It's just the other
23 hours of the day.
OK.
So App Standby ends when
the user launches your app,
obviously, or the
device is plugged in,
when all apps are released
from Standby Mode,
because we don't worry
about power anymore,
or when any work that
you're doing based
on your wakelock or
your Alarm Manager
is creating a notification.
Super, super easy.
But I guess you were
kind of wondering,
like, why really bother with
that if it's so much controlled
by the developer?
The main thing
about App Standby is
when you're in App
Standby mode, we
offer those periodic maintenance
windows, similar to Doze,
and you have a guaranteed
maintenance window of at least
once every 24 hours.
So think about an app
that you don't use often,
like maybe a movie
player, right?
Like, you want it
to be ready when
you're ready to buy, or
rent, or stream a movie.
But you're not going
to open it every day
or multiple times a day.
However, all of that content
that it offers to you,
that's licensed content.
And if you don't update
that license regularly,
you're legally obligated
to delete the content,
because it's an
ownership question.
And so in order to let
the content be refreshed,
and change the list of
movies, and in order
to make sure they're all valid
from the things you already
paid for as a user, you need
a periodic maintenance window.
But your app doesn't need
to be syncing all the time
or like three times a day,
because you might not use it
for two months at a time.
But it doesn't mean it's
not one of your go-to apps.
Similar to things like
buying a movie ticket,
all of these things are
very useful applications.
They're just not
used all day long.
And that's why we
created this, because we
want to empower those
applications while also trying
to let them know that they're
not-- don't drain the battery.
We'll put you together
with a bunch of others,
and everyone will have
a much better time.
But the trick here
is you probably still
don't have to do anything.
If you're reacting to a
broadcast or a message the way
you normally would, then you're
going to produce a notification
and get yourself out of standby.
And if you're
building an app that
runs a sync every so often,
it'll still run every day.
Like, still committing my
goal from the beginning.
We're not changing anything.
But when you do need to
adapt for App Standby,
it's exactly the same as before.
A GCM high-priority message
will break through and give you
network access, that you
can run a sync in response
to some sort of message.
And so really, all you have to
do is a couple of tweaks here,
and then you're really
good to go, if anything.
Like I said, maybe it
doesn't affect your app.
But that CPU time,
that network access,
you can get it in response
to something important.
But keep in mind what
counts as high priority.
If you don't want to get
up from writing some code,
and go and check
your phone, probably
don't want your user to have
to interrupt their day when
they're not actually
on the device.
OK.
So this results
in a final list of
like, why did you
tell me all this?
What do I actually have to do?
Do I have to test my app or not?
And I mean, you do.
That's true.
Both App Standby
and Doze, they're
going to be affecting your app.
No matter what you do,
you're kind of stuck with it.
It's part of
Marshmallow devices.
It's coming.
So you should be
considering this already.
But we need to keep radio and
CPU off as long as possible,
so the device can stay on.
And you have to have
all apps participating
in this to achieve this goal.
Just a few active ones that
are exceptions but can actually
undermine the entire purpose
of an Idle mode, right?
So the key here is to
understand what has changed.
You can't depend solely
on wakelocks and alarms,
because their behavior
isn't exactly right.
And if you have something
that is critical or sensitive,
you're catching yourself here.
However, you can count on the
fact that all of these things
are going to trigger.
They just might be deferred.
So really, nothing changes
in the overall picture.
Like I said, you may
be in a situation
where Doze has put your device
a couple hours out of date.
And you won't notice that
until the user picks it up.
And then it runs a sync.
So maybe there's a
long loading window.
And if that's bad
for your application,
you need to be considering
that when you're
scheduling your jobs
and your syncs, which
leads to my To Do list.
Super duper hard.
Like I said, considering
the flow of your app,
you need to make sure
that everything behaves
the way that it should behave
for the best user experience,
with the potential of
being a couple hours late.
You need to update any
time-critical alarms
to include AndAllowWhileIdle.
And you need to consider
any urgent or critical
downstream messages as
high-priority with GCM.
And finally, you really have
to actually test your app.
You need to see how it
reacts to a sync or a job
when it's delayed
because of Doze.
And if you're not
happy, you have
to return to step one and
do the whole thing again.
But if you actually are
happy, then you're done.
Like, that's all the
integration that's
required for Doze, which
leads me up here to stand up
here and stress again that
this sounds like a really
frustrating thing,
because developers
don't have any power here.
But we actually designed
it so thoughtfully
that you shouldn't have to
do hardly anything at all.
There are a few special cases
that we really did think about.
Like, you really do need
to know what's going
on here, what's going on there.
And then maybe
you're frustrated,
because the 15-minute
window doesn't work for you.
But you're also
considering the fact
of if you can't get the
user's attention with an alarm
every 15 minutes,
they might really
be doing something
important, which goes back
to my toothbrush test.
Like, users do have lives.
And it's hard to remember that,
because you get into this point
where you've spent
your whole life
kind of every day
building this thing that
matters so much to you.
But if you think about it from
a user perspective, how do
you use it, and how
will your user use it,
and what does it
do to the battery?
We're all trying to make
a better system here, make
a better ecosystem.
And that's why we
have Doze mode.
So test it, test it
thoroughly, test it using adb.
It's pretty great.
And we have a special one also
for App Standby with Inactive.
And you can set Inactive
or not to put yourself
on the standby list and see
how your app interacts there.
All of this is documented
thoroughly online.
We have a couple of
videos to help you out.
And of course, you
can always message me
with specific questions,
or any feedback,
or anything you want to know.
If you want to learn more about
how actually background tasks
work in general, I'm going
to go over that at 4 o'clock,
how to use Job Service, how
to build an intent service
or use a broadcast receiver, how
to actually make a background
task, because that's a
completely different problem.
But as for saving your
tasks from Doze mode,
you really, hopefully,
shouldn't have to worry.
It shouldn't be
any work for you.
And I hope that that's what
you discover with your app.
OK.
Cool.
You're all done really
early, so if you
want to ask me questions, I'll
just be, like, right here.
We've got 15 minutes every
day back to go get lunch.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]